what is happening with you in general
about the world championship cycle
because you are not playing ding is not
playing much you know he's the world
champion now the candidates will happen
and it's going on uh it feels something
is missing you know in the entire cycle
uh I would say at the moment it's not my
it's not my problem so I I know that uh
the world championship is very important
both to a lot of players and fans I mean
the classical World Championship
but yeah for the moment I'm not trying
to change anything nor am I playing the
playing the candidates
so I mean you are right that it's it's
it's a shame that the world champion is
not playing and uh that the best player
in the world is not playing in the world
classical World Championship but it's
the way it is